Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
les doy la bienvenida hoy desde el
noroeste de Francia Carrusel de las
artes los lleva a descubrir el festival
travelling de cine que se realiza cada
año en esta ciudad pero también les
hablaremos de un nuevo inmortal y de
música francesa
[Música]
La Academia francesa recibió con
solemnidad a Mario Vargas llosa El
escritor y Nobel peruano se convirtió
así en un guardián inmortal de la lengua
demoliá Santiago de Chile y su
efervescencia cinematográfica presentes
en la edición número 34 del festival
travelling de Ren seis décadas de
producción plasmadas en unas 90
películas filmadas antes durante y
después de la dictadura y en París
conoceremos a un nuevo Dúo Franco
británico de la escena emergente son los
Maybe Merlín
[Música]
el 9 de febrero Mario Vargas llosa entró
en la academia francesa como miembro
vitalicio convirtiéndose así en el
primer autor en integrar esta
institución sin haber escrito ni un solo
libro en francés Carrusel de las artes
estuvo en esa ceremonia bajo la cúpula
de La Academia y Melissa barra nos
relata lo que fue ese momento solemne
en medio del redoble de tambores de la
guardia republicana rodeado de sus
nuevos colegas académicos y vestido del
tradicional traje con bordado verde y la
emblemática espada de Los Inmortales
Mario Vargas llosa tomó su puesto en el
sillón 18 de la histórica academia
pronunció un discurso a manera de
declaración de amor a las letras
francesas una pasión que lo llevó a
instalarse en París en 1959
[Música]
Joaquín París quien me convertí en
escritor Pero además fue donde descubría
yustable quien fue y será siempre mi
maestro desde que compré un ejemplar de
Madame bovari el mismo día de mi llegada
sin flovera jamás hubiera podido ser
quien soy ni escribir lo que escribí es
gracias a él que hoy ustedes me reciben
Por lo cual les agradezco infinitamente
con el rey emérito de España en Primera
fila del público concluyó su discurso
alabando la literatura como arte
superior a todos los demás y como fuente
de libertad
a la democracia la novela salvará la
democracia o se hundirá con ella y
desaparecerá dijo el Nobel de literatura
criticando la censura y apuntando
directamente a Vladimir Putin de este
modo Mario Vargas llosa se convirtió en
el primer escritor en lengua no francesa
en entrar a la prestigiosa institución
encargada de perfeccionar el idioma
francés
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Gracias Melissa Barry como les decíamos
nos encontramos en el festival
travelling de que celebra cada año la
cinematografía de una ciudad en el mundo
y este año el foco estuvo sobre la
capital chilena a través de una
selección de películas que muestran la
producción prolífica y ecléctica de
Santiago de Chile en los últimos 60 años
chile piensa en su futuro
soy perseguido en el último sitio del
mundo donde yo hubiese querido que eso
ocurriera aquí en Chile la capital
chilena como epicentro de luchas y
sobresaltos y a la vez vivero de la
creación cinematográfica contemporánea
eso es lo que mostró el festival
travelling a través de casi 90 películas
desde el cine excéntrico de Raúl Ruiz la
observación político poética de Patricio
Guzmán Hasta los cineastas más jóvenes
como Pablo larraín o Sebastián
[Aplausos]
leliotón Santiago no es una ciudad
cinematográfica como París Londres o
Nueva York que tienen elementos que
identifican a esas ciudades Santiago es
más una ciudad símbolo la capital de las
decisiones de las tomas de poder de la
lucha y de las contradicciones en su
cine queda claro que el país no ha
pasado la página completamente sin
embargo conviven otras temáticas ligadas
a la realidad que viven los chilenos el
día el día que no siempre es fácil la
división social del país es algo que se
hace evidente en el cine moderno muchas
películas hablan de esto a través de
retratos creo que el cine chileno es un
cine de retratos
Esta película es un pedazo de la memoria
de chile estas imágenes avanzan hacia
las imágenes que se comienzan a borrar
el golpe de estado contra Allende y la
irrupción de la dictadura militar
condenaron a muchos cineastas al exilio
otros como Ignacio Agüero se aferraron
al cine Como instrumento de creación y
de denuncia incluso desde la
clandestinidad El golpe mató muchas
cosas de partida mató muchos artistas no
mató enteramente el arte ni el
movimiento de resistencia La dictadura
fue derrotada finalmente como cineastas
nosotros sabíamos que íbamos a hacer
película y que teníamos que hacerlas
entonces de algún modo esa pocas
películas que hice yo Por lo menos en
dictadura eran películas hechas con
miedo pero por otro lado era hacer lo
que yo quería hacer que era ser cineasta
también decidí quedarme y eso fue
tenía un costo pero también tenía su
gratificación si algún día hace una
Revolución que incluya las locas avísame
ahí voy a estar yo en Primera fila
Aunque la militancia desde el cine ha
sido una constante los directores de hoy
se han apropiado de otros géneros y
temáticas el documental el melodrama o
lo fantástico historias que han llegado
a la cima de la industria
cinematográfica mundial
[Aplausos]
y tiene por su parte Domínguez sotomayor
ha ganado premios en los festivales de
locano y de rotterdam con cintas poco
convencionales de jueves a domingo y
tarde para morir joven creo que me
interesaban como
situaciones mucho más mínimas como no
grandes historias no quizás las cosas
que salen en los diarios o que se pueden
escribir me interesa más documentar
procesos intermedios que no son quizás
tan interesantes históricamente Pero eso
creo que también puede ser político el
hecho de presentar un punto de vista
sobre las cosas y hacerlo público ella
es político y también Creo que el hecho
de hacer un cine no convencional y que
cuestiona la forma y que hace al
espectador cuestionarse y incomodarse
otros lugares también es establecer una
mirada que se podría decir que es
política porque empuja a una
transformación O al menos tiene una
ilusión de transformación en las
personas
el festival travelyn presentó este año
una selección de Cintas chilenas y
animación y allí También la sombra de la
dictadura ha estado presente pero con
historias cargadas de poesía humor o
Esperanza chile es también un país con
una fuerte tradición documental un
espacio de innovación y conexión con la
identidad y la historia
el intento por borrar la historia que
pueda haber hecho la dictadura en este
caso fue un ataque a la identidad
chilena pero no es tan fácil atacar una
memoria cuando es cultural sobrevive de
muchas maneras y el documental hace un
trabajo especialmente en ese lugar no
Por supuesto que hay documentales de
diversos tipos pero ahí sí yo reconozco
que hay una tendencia del género
documental chileno hacia una memoria
nacional hace una memoria histórica hay
muchas historias que son las historias
de los derrotados digamos no la historia
oficial sino las historias que quedaron
al margen de la oficialidad pero que
existen todavía y que son quizás la
parte más rica de nuestra identidad y
que si queremos efectivamente seguir
avanzando no podemos tener esta Amnesia
en torno a nuestra identidad yo creo que
ahí es un hay un rol fundamental que
cumple el documental Y por ahí me
aventuraría también a explicar por qué
está este auge está maravilloso por lo
demás del del género documental en Chile
Cuál es el sentido de la vida el cerebro
hace preguntas el corazón da las
respuestas la vida no tiene sentido vive
vive
[Música]
damos paso ahora nuestra Crónica musical
y para ello conectamos en París con
Natalia Olivares quien nos hace
descubrir a un Dúo Franco británico de
la escena emergente francesa sí Hola
María Carolina estamos en las afueras de
París en Montoya en los estudios
albatros justamente aquí hace un siglo
más de un siglo atrás nacieron los
primeros estudios de cine europeo y aquí
también Vienen a ensayar bastante grupos
musicales entre ellos Maybe Merlin el
Dúo Franco británico vamos a ver qué
pasa detrás de esta historia de amor
musical
[Música]
el color musical de Maybe Merlín nació
del suelo es una música con tintes de
tierra para nuestro primer encuentro
había preparado unas cuantas bucles de
colores musicales diferentes y
finalmente se eligió el más anclado en
el suelo el más lento el más rítmico
podemos decir que el universo de Maybe
Merlín viene de esa mezcla y
afortunadamente porque somos dos la
danza tuvo un papel importante en el
color musical
[Música]
la música de Los Maybe Marlin nació y se
escribió con una evidencia y las
palabras También tienen su historia en
parte es una herencia del papá de
Georgia artista fallecido en 2007
en nuestra primera sesión de estudio
Georgia trajo un montón de textos que
había escrito de su padre que era inglés
una gran pila improvisamos Y empezamos a
trabajar con sus fragmentos de texto y
luego llamamos autores talentosos de
nuestro entorno venga te toca a ti
Hablar ahora
le conté que mi padrino era Boris
bergman es el letrista de Alan y otros
tantos artistas pero teníamos miedo de
pedirle que escribiera para nosotros las
ganas eran Tales de que organizamos el
encuentro yo creo que él quería
continuar la historia de mi padre y
logró crear un equipo de creación luego
también se lo pedimos a un amigo nuestro
yágono
fue diferente porque cantó la emoción de
nuestro piloto luego nos hizo mil
preguntas y así fue nos escribió las
canciones a la medida
eso Y eso es suerte
[Música]
una fusión musical evidente entre el
multi instrumentalista
quien creció en el mundo de la danza una
pasión que resultó ser la base de sus
creaciones musicales
yo soy coreógrafa y me encanta trabajar
con los no bailarines es una cuestión de
energía y la fusión en el escenario se
dio de forma natural porque el cuerpo de
Georgia se mueve solo
como músico tiene una facilidad escénica
mi aporte fue solo darle un extra de
confianza decirle No tengas miedo con
sus instrumentos Él ya sabe recrear el
espacio y cuenta con un carisma que todo
se le conocemos eso es lo bonito reunir
diferentes cuerpos y tener movimientos
distintos en una misma canción
[Música]
gracias Natalia Oli con los Maybe y
Merlin vamos a terminar este programa
especial que les presentamos desde la
ciudad de arena Muchísimas gracias por
su fidelidad y hasta un nuevo Carrusel
de las Artes maxia
[Música]